arch the Beast arch the Beast is the
name let's see him place like a beast
oops okay the night off yeah maybe
Bishop g5 for a change I have no idea
about theory but okay maybe this kind of
move should be should be okay in a way
Bishop d7 is somewhat uncommon line I
guess okay retreat all here maybe just
castling long
funny way to play the rookie is somewhat
somewhat special really wonder if I can
make any use of that like let's say
queen d 1 and then if I've on or is the
rook just the liability okay I'll drop
back and play Bishop d3 next shoring up
the center
he's writing to me that he's watching
the channel it's always funny okay okay
Bishop e7 so is there 94 no I don't
think so oh it's must be alert with this
bishop on each form somewhat hanging
with 94 this B should be formed that
that's okay for what get this counter
play in the center maybe you can play d5
no cannot
maybe hmm ok well let's see what he's
doing and many moves possible here Queen
a5 b5 I have my doubt that he that he is
going to castle but I mean castling
short but even that might be a move re i
cannot play you five at the moment yeah
he's just castling ok I'm I'm pushing
him maybe d5 now but I know I must I was
play moves and I'm head on the clock for
once this is a something to to use not
spending ages now and fall behind again
on the clock ok well chief I if I it
looks dangerous isn't this dangerous for
like k Bishop takes I guess
and why I've got rook g1 look G to wear
this is quick okay I wonder if he placed
before what what am I going to do
against that 9595 looks very yeah very
forceful but the question is is it
really necessary that's the main problem
i think i can just go to eat too there's
really no use oh no need for for
anything fancy 94 can come with the
temple in the right moment and let's
still have root g one green age three
and so on yeah that looks quite nice
okay um King bee wonders b3m maybe hmm
that's funny yeah but I cannot really
let him take on HM well that's that's
really not good
interesting
and I don't really see a something else
huh yeah now it's got be 30 funny b3m us
plain Knight c3 takes on a 2 and King a
one that's a funny line and TS encounter
plane so maybe I should have thought a
bit after this be formless if there was
something better than 90 to wear this
this looks like definite counterplay I
wonder why it's not playing b3 I mean
what else relief this is like totally
false Yemen check I couldn't take with
the night SD for a v2 was still hanging
the rock was laying ok so my defense key
move is 91 he might take one be too
though this this could be the real issue
ball
cool I cannot play 91 here and what is
that do I have any sort of defense I
maybe
and you may need to cover c3 somehow we
should be to a row p 2 is really a
substantial threat
huh
any way to defend out of that I don't
really see it maybe Bishop c4 I mean
this is probably losing you tonight xe4
but I didn't really see another move
okay we should be three I can take you
four of course but I have maybe rock g2
is just attacking 30-something seconds
okay hi morning no this Bishop is open
and this is protected so i can click
here maybe taking up seven take away
near six was terrible really why did i
do that it's now it's very tricky to get
even the slightest hint of something
okay well i can maybe a four look to you
one threatening look which is seven now
this this isn't this is something check
check okay this is Major but only only
because of the the little time left that
he had oh yeah well this is I was told
ya no no question no question yeah from
a very good position to a terrible
position I mean around here white should
be should be almost winning with the g
file but it's this is remarkable how
quickly this this counter play was a was
coming and now i know probably probably
night bolonia this this this is this is
terribly strong he had the computers
immediately giving black a win here
so maybe just for concrete reasons this
isn't so great yeah well I thought well
the G file but if it's not good for
concrete reasons it means that I cannot
play 92 but can I go somewhere else if I
go here there's still this one intending
be three so maybe I must go to go to
here and this is not ideal so ok I made
a mistake beforehand probably yeah
something like 95 is not not really any
sort of idea yeah there is no there is
no serious and take it seems he's got
this one and very important interesting
so I was really lost here you have
amazing really amazing the computer is
giving a very funny line and this means
it's not so clear actually the computer
wants to play that intending to trap the
Queen haha and it gives it the position
as about equal interesting
check this is even losing the Queen does
not have any square this is check an
easy line I can play that though funny
with this idea and tags yeah and I've
got a pawn for the exchange not two not
so clear this position probably good for
black in some way but not not totally
totally simple yeah this was played and
no I'm lost him mmm it took some time
here I didn't find any move ready this
is also not not really working if I've
yeah it's just winning but if I was even
quicker yeah this is really the last
sort of idea and now just 11 prep move
King evade or something it's is winning
and this is a checkmate yeah what I'm
wondering how is this a maid actually
okay yeah okay jealous check Andrew J it
okay yeah that's a bit of a tragic end I
mean here it's really a checkmate he has
no way to prevent it check and check
this would have been the end of the game
yeah the time the time cost him you had
a very good position and it's quite
interesting I mean just the first
impression i think is really like white
is in excellent shape the g fat is
already open and i have root g 2 root g
one it looks like yeah black is not
going to survive for ten moves but this
before in FF counter plays very concrete
and strong amazing alright thanks for
watching